the government made a mistake they've
realized they've made a mistake they've
changed it they're moving on
chaos though isn't it absolute chaos in
government and I think you've just been
talking about the markets having
losing confidence in the government
maybe as a result of this picking up a
little bit but I think it does have a
long-term effect in the markets because
the question now is will be when they
make a decision will they stick with a
decision so that loses confidence but
also it isn't just the markets you know
it's the electorate as well I think
members of the public now were shocked
at the budget itself from the 45p in
particular but there's lots of other
elements of that budget as well and
there's a fear now of some of those
other elements like the cuts
incorporation tax being reversed
National Insurance increase being
reversed all of that being paid for now
by another round of austerity so there's
real anxieties about this government so
this this U-turn was forced upon them
purely and simply because they realized
they couldn't get it through Parliament
Tory MPS would have voted against it so
I welcome that but it's just chaos in
government isn't it really
well it's not really because they're in
charge and your part is not
no but they've and as demonstrated as a
government you know they launched a new
era supposedly only 10 days ago that new
eras hasn't lasted very long has it and
you get decision making on the hoof like
this demonstrates that there is chaos
and for the life of me I cannot
understand why they brought this about
it was completely unnecessary the
refusal to have the office of budget
responsibility to play a role in
advising them I thought was bizarre and
then also at the same time to sack the
Tom scholar the respected permanent
secretary in the treasury all of this
demonstrated to me that this was a a new
leadership of the Tory party that really
hadn't thought this through and that's
why I do think it is chaotic in
government at the moment you know
yesterday we had senior conservative MPS
publicly basically saying to the prime
minister so we won't support this and
thank goodness they did because it's the
only thing that seems to have stopped
her going ahead with this lunacy
um
yeah um we're talking about
um labor Being Fit for office obviously
it's changed significantly since Jeremy
corbyn uh wanted to be prime minister
and you very much supported him do you
on reflection realize he was the wrong
man for the job no not at all we came
close to winning in 2017. we lost in
2019 it was a brexit election we just
couldn't break through on that one
however things have moved on the worst
results since the 1930s and it was a it
was we were caught on the horns of
brexit I'm afraid we couldn't shoot one
way or the other without losing quite
significant support whether moving to
remain or leave and it was a brexit
election we've moved on though brexit is
no longer an issue what we are dealing
with now is the basic bread and butter
issues of what people are facing and out
there in my constituency and elsewhere
it's tough you know inflation 10
wages increasing by maybe two or three
so wage Cuts we're facing another round
of austerity when we've got the stats on
poverty okay a horrendous set number 14
million people in poverty five million
children we had a report two weeks ago
about two million children being hungry
in our country that's the reality of
what we're facing and so I think people
have said after 12 years of a
conservative government this is the mess
we're in they're making even bigger mess
with this budget therefore it's time to
give labor a chance and I can completely
see why the polls are showing the way
they are at the moment because people
have just had enough
said the whip suspended he's not allowed
to represent labor in the House of
Commons
I think that's a mistake I'm hoping here
and the chief whip will change their
mind on what on that one the Jeremy's a
labor party member for the life of me I
think you know he's been an excellent
constituency MP he's got huge support in
his constituency and I hope they'll
think again and we can unite the party
on this particular issue because now is
the time to have a United party where
we're demonstrating the sort of
political program that will take us into
government what's interesting you know
for the first time the polls now we've
got a big poll lead for the a lot of
that originally was with conservative
voters moving to don't know for the
first time now we're getting
conservative voters switching to labor I
think that's as a result the chaos of
the leadership of the Tory pass but I
also think it's as a result of that some
of the policy program announced by KIA
storm at the late Party Conference last
week and you know what those policies
are the ones that actually we've been
campaigning for the last five years and
our last manifestos and I saw one
journalist actually said that um care
speech was more John McDonald than Tony
Blair which I I think it most probably
was
goodness
um um how modest of you
um
just to be clear you're suggesting that
the present day labor party is based on
the shoulders of Jeremy corbyn's
policies and yours I'm saying I'm saying
if you look at what was announced last
week in terms of Care's policy program
look at some of the detail of that
bringing rail back into public ownership
there's another last two manifestos
the the Energy company that we're now
going to set up being in public
ownership whether we're developing a
public ownership of Becky long Bailey
developed that policy if you look at the
national wealth fund actually it's
virtually our national Investment Bank
that we had not on the scale we wanted
but moving that way setting up a
National Economic Council exactly what
we were doing so a lot of them reflect
of course they're they've moved on time
has moved on and understandably will
have new policies coming to deal with
the issues of today but a lot of it
reflected some of the policies that we
advocated as well and I welcome that I
labor party has always been a broad
Church left right and center and what
that's what I'm hoping care will do
bring everyone together so when we go
into the next election we have a policy
program that reflects the totality of
the thinking of our movement and in that
way I actually think we're going to
government with a strong policy program
that will reverse the disasters of this
last 12 years of continued austerity and
the mismanagement of our economy by the
Tories
and Jeremy corbyn should have a role in
any future labor cabinet what role
should he have
I think you should have the whip
returned I'm not sure Jeremy would want
to serve in the cabinet I think he
should have the whip return so he can be
the labor MP for Islington north um with
the mass popular support that he's got
in the Constitutions he had a huge
majority of the last election in his
constituency I think his constituents
would welcome him being reelected
um okay but if there are a lot of his
policies and your policies why would he
not want to be in cabinet
I think it's a new generation coming
through now I think we should encourage
that as well if you look at the range of
people on our front bench now there's
lots of talent there and I think they
should be given their head at their time
has come
good to talk to you thanks very much
indeed for joining us thank you